The swimmer had spent fifteen years chasing a single moment four hundred meters of water,
a blur of arms and legs, the gasping breath of exhaustion, and then, finally, the touch of the
wall. The crowd roared. The anthem swelled. For those few seconds on the podium, bathed in gold
in the weight of a nation's pride, she felt invincible. The world had stopped. She had
arrived. And then, she stepped back into the Olympic village. No fanfare. No transformation.
Just the same fluorescent lights, the same thin institutional coffee, the same hollow
echo of her own footsteps. She had won. And yet nothing. The medal around her neck felt
like a lead weight. The victory lap was just another loop in the same old race. Psychologists
call it the arrival fallacy. The lie we tell ourselves that if we just get there, if we
just sign the contract, finish the degree, buy the house, climb the mountain, we'll finally
be something. Something whole. Something happy. But the truth. The finish line is just another
starting point. And the starting point is always the same.
Our brains are wired for the chase, not the catch. Dopamine doesn't linger. It fades the
second we cross the line, leaving us staring at the same old horizon, wondering why the
view hasn't changed. So how do you master this? How do you ensure you never, ever feel complete?
First, you never stop moving. The second you get that promotion, you start plotting the next
one. The victory dinner becomes a strategy session. Celebration is just a pause in the grind. Because
if you let yourself rest, even for a second, you might realize the truth. The race was never about the
destination. It was about the illusion that there was one. Then you compare. Always compare. You buy the
house, and then you find the mansion. You write the book, and then you hunt down the Nobel laureate.
You measure yourself against someone else's peak, because your own is just a hill. The higher you
climb, the more you see how far you still have to go. And if that doesn't work, buy something.
Anything. A car that hums with newness. A watch that ticks like a metronome counting down to the next
upgrade. The thrill fades in weeks, of course. But by then, you've already spotted the next shiny
thing on the horizon. Hedonic adaptation is your friend. It keeps you running. But the real trick?
Never let your identity catch up. Be the job title, the achievement, the next milestone. Never the person
who just is. Because the second you stop doing, you're left with nothing. And nothing, my friend,
is the most dangerous arrival of all. The beauty of the air of all fallacy is that it never lets you
win. As long as you believe happiness is just one more climb away, you'll never be happy where you
are. You'll spend your life as an eternal traveler, dragging your luggage to a landscape that never
changes. Always convince that the next mountain is the real one. Congratulations, you've reached the
end of the menu. And now, the bill comes due. The peak is the most dangerous place to stand.
There is nowhere to go but down or toward another mountain you can never truly climb.